[Music]
it's 4:30 in the morning on a remote
mountaintop in Atlanta Pink Floyd blares
through an Shelton's headphones as he
meticulously maneuvers ten inch
telescope at Las Campanas Observatory
it's February 24th 1987 and Shelton a
telescope operator is having a rough
night
the observatory sliding roof door isn't
working when he arrived after finally
getting it open he spends three hours
painstakingly taking a picture of the
Large Magellanic Cloud a galaxy that
orbits the Milky Way suddenly a gust of
wind lamp the door closed and everything
goes black Shelton takes the hint maybe
I'll just call it a night the things are
about to look up he takes the eight by
ten photographic plate to the darkroom
and develops it checking the exposure
he immediately notices something odd and
there's this extra star that was
brighter effectively than all the other
ones after he widened I use that one to
line up the telescope because it wasn't
there he shouldn't be there
Shelton checks it against the previous
night's plate nope definitely not
supposed to be there he grabs his jacket
steps outside and looks up
sure enough there it is a bright point
of light near the tarantula nebula for
me I was just don't quite surprise to
the point I never a bit of disbelief so
Shelton heads down the road to check
with the guy that another telescope he
casually asked fellow astronomer Barry
Madore well let me just say but he could
magnitude object in the LMC Madore does
the map in his head and that's not
supernovae and then he looks at me you
know does the guilty you're kidding
that's one telescope operator asked or
do holiday chimes in yes I saw something
there too he was probably the first
person to see it naked eye
around 166 thousand light-years away a
hefty star had gone supernova it ran out
of fuel and its core collapsed starting
shockwave ghostly particles called
neutrinos helped push the shockwave to
the star surface and had exploded the
detonation filled the Stars chemical
guts into space its end would turn up
gaseous building blocks for stellar
construction Shelton and his colleagues
for seeing this distant Lake show a 166
thousand years later as close to real
time as he could get the last time
someone had directly observed a
supernova with the naked eye was in 1604
so the crew at last companion has to get
the word out except no one knows the
protocol for notifying the International
Astronomical Union about a supernova
Shelton digs up an old article in sky &
Telescope magazine that simple half page
quarter page opening how to report to
discovery he tries calling the IU office
in Massachusetts you know it rang and
rang in writing but it doesn't rip icked
up
then i go to plan B send a telegram they
scribble a note and instructions on
piece of paper the driver says offers
closest town la serena about a hundred
kilometers away in search of the tell
exhibition the equivalents of email
today the Astronomy community it was big
big news and I guess everybody doubled
now this is the big one Shelton
supernova became known as 1987a its
proximity to earth meant it could be
viewed with the naked eyes of southern
hemisphere a rare treat stars go
supernova
all the time in the universe but 1987a
confirmed a lot of things that
distraught emerge to be arrived about
the death of stars it also marked the
first supernova where astronomers could
pinpoint the identity of the progenitor
star the newly AK - 69 - oh - and it was
the first time
researchers detected neutrinos from a
stellar explosion in 30 years in Shelton
caption 1987 a fiery blast some
scientists is still learning in from the
supernova and the remaining news it left
behind in the meantime Shelton and
others await their next opportunity to
see a star explode
[Music]
you